a five-year-old went into a Children's
Hospital Colorado for a procedure to
remove some tissue from underneath the
tongue that was causing her sort of a
speech impediment making it difficult to
say certain sounds and it's a story
about so many of the things that are
wrong with our healthcare system the
doctor who did the procedure said hey to
the mom by the way while your daughter
is under anesthesia
we can also pierce her ears she might
like that and the mom said okay that's
fine the bill for the operating room
services related specifically to the
piercing ended up being one thousand
eight hundred and seventy seven dollars
and eighty six cents nearly nineteen
hundred dollars for ear piercing the
insurance company said hey that's
cosmetic and optional we aren't paying
for that just because ear piercings are
cheap at the mall doesn't mean that
they're cheap at a hospital when a
surgeon does ear piercing at a hospital
during a surgery it's no longer a Sunday
afternoon at Claire's accessories at the
local mall right it is now a Surgical
ear piercing which is actually really
rare there's only a few dozen cases that
were uncovered by the healthcare cost
institute because again it's a cosmetic
procedure and insurance doesn't cover it
when you do it in a hospital now
eventually after a long story that I
won't bore you with the mom made a huge
stink and they were given a credit for
the ear piercing it was forgiven as a
courtesy by the hospital but there are
many issues here to talk about right as
far as this hospital is concerned the
mom is saying the doctor suggested that
we do this without mentioning that it
wouldn't be covered and it's cosmetic
and then they wrote it up as saying that
I asked for it which isn't true and
there's a whole bunch of issues as to
whether the hospital and the surgeon
were honest about this but I want to
talk about the systemic problems which
were way worse and the real systemic
problem is that one thousand eight
hundred and seventy seven dollars for
ear piercing is actually in line with
industry standards for these so called
in the hospital surgical ear piercings
and there are endless reasons for this
you can't blame just one thing prices go
up because insurance will only reimburse
part of what the hospital bills if the
hospital wants a hundred and fifty bucks
and insurance usually only pay seventy
five percent of what the hospital wants
well the hospital needs to charge 200 in
order to end up with a hundred and fifty
dollars but of course that's not all you
also have to make up for people who come
into the hospital but without insurance
at all you have to treat them right you
can't turn them away and a lot of them
will never never pay at all so if that
accounts for five percent of the dollars
you bill
well you make up for it by adding 5
percent to all the prices so that it
ends up being covered these are crude
numbers right but you get the idea and
then on top of that ear-piercing like
everything else has to conform to the
billing protocol the medical billing
protocol that's in place which means
that the doctor needs to spend time
writing up the procedure and approved
language in this case it was a bilateral
the bilateral lobules were prepped with
betadine and an 18-gauge was used to
pierce the left lobule in the planned
position blah blah blah that means that
medical time is spent describing
procedures often for insurance companies
and that adds to the cost because it's
time and then everything is itemized in
a way that you need a professional
medical biller to even do it that is an
entire apparatus the medical billing
apparatus that further increase the cost
so you get the idea
that's how we end up with a two thousand
dollar ear piercing
do you think that the doctors suspected
that this could have happened or just
ignored it altogether I don't I mean you
have to be straightforward with the
family that this is gonna cost you
nearly $2,000 there were some comments
saying that the doctors aren't involved
in the billing so they're totally
disconnected like the doctor genuinely
may have just thought hey while she's
under let's pierce her ears with no idea
that hey these are cosmetic procedures
that your insurance won't cover and will
cost two grand I don't know the answer
to that but the fact that it was written
up as something that the mom requested
even though the mom says the doctor
offered it is a little bit suspect so
this is horrible there's no sign that
this is going to get better and under
Trump if anything it's going to get even
worse